where to clean podcast and welcome to
[ __ ] punch John sports where winners
win yes ah Jason Tebow has a job today
so he's out there hustling making that
cheddar gonna upgrade those leafs gonna
go to maybe some acorns I don't know
maple maple Eve so joining us is our
podcast royalty you know them as the
voice of clip cast my good friend Mike
Jacqueline how are you mind great the
Jaguar I put out your you don't like you
don't like these I thought you're a
podcaster I use a zoom zoom yeah yeah
welcome to profession here flip it flip
it the other way so you can know now we
how we can hear you see there we go I'm
amongst royalty now yeah is now I'm not
in a Subaru yeah a podcast doctor
quality is phenomenal in a Subaru it
does it those Japanese are like we make
car so you podcast no there's a small
sec of Japan that speaks with an
Australian dialect
they were taken over by Paul Hogan yeah
I 91
dude you just don't realize that was so
much farther than you even understood
and you just ruined it and everyone's
laughing at you we're at a dialect
convention ever it'll be like who's the
[ __ ] you are you said there's a section
shut up hey uh what's going on with clip
cast well I mean we're wrapping up the
season tomorrow
we don't know again where the Clippers
are gonna fall tonight's a big night in
the NBA yeah OKC at Houston at OKC that
basically determines a lot Houston could
possibly move up to the two and OKC
could stay away from the good old
warriors which are the Clippers er
statistically I can't believe we're
eight we're all the way up to five well
I mean this guy we lose the Lakers why
did we lose to Alex Caruso have you seen
that man's hairline
he's just throw there's not a lot of
things I hate in sports well mums
coach Carey okay
number two is WNBA players in all-star
weekend and number three is [ __ ] pro
athletes with male pattern baldness and
[ __ ] tits those [ __ ] piss me off
shake your head there's so many cures I
mean there's so many options for men
love the [ __ ] bald head right that
get you excited
it's the nipples rocking the bald guys
look at how much hair jeff has he like
could feel of you further from balls now
there's like you know it's like four
guys right we know certain girls bring
certain kind of heat right do guys like
those jus dick bringing a little harder
than like like like [ __ ] Mormon dick
or [ __ ] a Christian dick or Buddhist
and I have had to have slept with the
Mormon to compare okay but we know
you've slept with a lot of people like
great ball three people it's a great
non-scripted show I thank you thank you
let's take a let's do an experiment
yeah of men and women yeah sleeping with
different let's power rank the hump and
yeah and I think Mexicans gonna take it
for the ladies though Mexicans are two
chicks
they'll be in and out it it out yeah
exactly
Johnny we're talking are you gonna join
us or is your is your software rebooting
cleaning Christian clean and Christian
guys I am going to be in Nashville this
Friday I'm at the Nashville Comedy
Festival
it is tinfoil hat Eddie Bravo myself
Brett Bach we will be live at the
National Comedy Festival and then
Saturday we are in Huntsville Alabama
dude
I'm going to Alabama to tell jokes I'm
so excited and we're gonna be at the
Huntsville stand-up live we got like a
really good time slot - I can't believe
they gave us a great time slot like they
did but we got it and we're rockin they
didn't put you in the middle of the day
with like a spring college guy I don't
mind as long as football's not on I
don't mind a 5 o'clock Saturday show
it's all [ __ ] it's like I've said for
years about like the women Lakers make
the playoffs in LA
kills yeah
that's why commies thriving in LA cuz
the Lakers [ __ ] sucked
it's a very good point yeah well 100%
did we'll see what happens - aye aye
I think the Lakers are gonna get two of
these three people ad boogie cousins or
Kyrie I think they're gonna get two of
them I disagree and I give him I give
them put on your headphones there's no
sound is that what you mean no buzzing
yeah these new yes they are there's no
tape on them no they have real
headphones is this a plug for fries down
the street yeah what this is is this is
Oni this is you know the podcast we're
kind of like the Mad Men of podcasting
where we women are second-class citizens
and they get all the jump I had broken
headphones for the last year and you
didn't say anything no I never would
they would like buzz and like give me a
really bad migraine I felt like I was
like I did not lift up them and gave
them to me that soon I think I could say
I get told I broke down we didn't break
them I didn't I did it I did it during
an anger I can see you slap them down
you're very very calm thank you Johnny
could you have more computers going at
one point you had your phone it's a
computer you have two phones [ __ ] I
have one you have two phones I do it I
mean I've won well I I'm trying to tweet
about the show share it share it I like
it what do you guys want to start off
with
wait attorney last night you were pissed
the whole time dude this guy [ __ ]
drunk text me the whole night he know I
know I would never I barely would watch
the game I was watching the Braves play
you're watching the Braves play I are I
watched [ __ ] Virginia why it's like hate
I hate the pack line defense is so
boring the way they play on offense [ __ ]
those guys I didn't deserve it they
escaped three times they played shitty
teams all the way through play every
team they played was in the bottom like
10% of pace of play it was the perfect
they just gave him us cheesecake but
they want I mean the last three games
øt yeah and and they mean Oracle against
Purdue they needed a guy to foul yeah
mr. Kyle guy yeah and who actually won
tourney and maybe it's because I'm an
ACC you guys yeah I have to watch it's
brutal its dreadful yeah it's the death
of basketball I let's see what the radio
but the ladies weren't gonna be good
that pissed me off because that just
makes it so that these rafts and the
league rigged the games with the [ __ ]
trying to get Duke to the finals and
it's just like I don't want to live in
that world but it's a good story you had
a team that lost to a 16 seed the year
prior comes back and wins it two teams
that have never been in the championship
of the final okay and listen on paper
she wasn't pretty but she had big tits
yeah and that's what that game was they
over hit you know yeah that's that's
like Jason Tebow's joke about you know
what's the what's the the [ __ ] second
thing about a [ __ ] chick with big
tits you notice that she's [ __ ] yeah
I got big tits down 15% from the last
time the title game was on CBS
yeah bo to Villanova LA last year so I
mean you know that was an all-time low
game but it's the ratings were down 15%
from the last time they were on CBS two
years ago okay so two years ago the last
year was on TNT I would assume then they
must have been yeah yeah well you put on
cable they would not have cable by the
way that people are cutting cords yeah
you know people want course you know FK
but you don't have any TV right probably
as you know I have TV you but you only
have the network so you don't have
anything else
oh sorry were you saying do you who does
not who has able no I'm like who doesn't
who has network but not cable Ryan
anyone with rabbit ears who I don't have
a my dad really has that yeah rabbit
ears yeah and he won't get cable he's so
weird about it and he thinks netflix is
like blows his mind he's like oh no one
understood why I can watch it all one
day yeah I'm like dad you would love
Netflix I'm like it's very cheap you
would have so much TV because he's
always complaining there's nothing on TV
of course I got my dad
Smart TV my dad wouldn't know what to do
did your dad know what to do well dude
it's literally this most simpler [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] saying no I tell me and
my dad's not always a $200 television
yeah oh yeah and it's already got it in
a dude the baby doesn't have feet for
two days take two days off from the baby
eden and buy your dad a flat TV but he
just wouldn't even he'd be like now I
have a monthly bill he'd be on that
there's no monthly bill he doesn't even
like have wife my dad's weird yeah he
doesn't have a smartphone heals like it
found that opens and closes oh by the
way I'm about two years from your father
he does this on purpose her father is
actually kind of like the reason why
like I think streaming hasn't gone full
circle I'm like Middletown America oh
yeah what you have yeah yeah you know
and like you have all the Millennials
and all these people in big cities
trying to cut cords my dad lives in
upstate Wisconsin he's not gonna be able
to stream the woods yeah you know Wi-Fi
out there they do but it's like you're
it's not the same like rock getting
direct it's like old Wi-Fi getting
DIRECTV was like cable coming towards
sure yeah usually so many people like
boxing now when it's not on HBO when
they and they move it over to ESPN plus
my dad who's a huge boxing man he just
doesn't get to watch boxing now because
do you mean with us pulling out his iPad
is not oh yeah man let's not forget the
big show this Saturday Night Live at the
dojo inside the Sycamore tavern will not
be there it is punch drunks UFC 236
viewing party and stand-up the lineup is
stacked even though I will be in Sweet
Home Alabama we have Jason Tebow Kareem
Matthews the guys from dirty spores
Eddie IFFT um other people it's only $10
on Eventbrite it's really good [ __ ] dude
then you fight them during them there we
go who else Oh Trevor Cavallo who has no
punchlines and Danis
O'Neil there we go look at that that's a
killer lineup plus we have some other
people gonna stop by I think Jamie kills
teens go stop by and I think Josh Jenni
will stop by and rock by the way
Trevor's face is like where's that punch
line eyewear Z so last night's game who
do you like out of that to go pro I mean
DeAndre hunter who was the game leader
for the entire season has been a lottery
pick I think now he's jumped up probably
into that Fordyce ten range
he could go top three he's I think he's
a poor man's Kawhi Leonard he plays in
an awful boring offense but he guards
every position he shut down Zion
multiple times this year so hard to
project or when players out of that
often it really is but you can't teach
defense as we saw in with those teams
but also in the NBA I think it's
something that you miss and if you have
a two-way player like a DeAndre hunter
that's better than a shooting guard then
call over nicole ver I know yeah yeah
yeah yeah I would rather have DeAndre
hunters than Culver even though I got
the ground ray hunter I want you it
looks like I was rocking so hard I feel
like what he will bring to a team yeah
yeah yeah you know that really looks
like quite a guy thing I heard last year
yeah before the tournament returned yeah
right now sophomore I think it's a
junior
um sophomore sophomore okay and then
Culver is a sophomore as well but I just
you know what you're getting with him
you're gonna tell me if like Atlanta
ends up with him but he wouldn't be a
perfect guy with Trey young yeah a 3d
guy that I you know RJ Bennett I'm
telling you right now dude I like
Bennett I mean dude he was Barnett
Barnett whatever Barrett Barrett okay
really want to take a shot at it yeah
you think I don't know you're talking
about that'll always be my favorite
that's how you pronounce things thank
you five I feel like RJ Berry's got more
scoring up side then those guys but lost
on defense
I feel like dude they gave him all these
chances to to hit the game-winning shot
he during the crunch time and he'd get
the ball desire he didn't touch the ball
the last minute 40 like he didn't get
shot up the last minute 40 of their loss
how do you I mean how does K that's the
worst coaching job who's the guy waiting
sit who's the guy who came from Duke
last year and went to the Bulls Kennard
Wendell Carter oh yeah he ripped Coach K
on the way out he's like that guy
promise me this then they brought in the
other guy that went to Sacramento
Wendell Carter did yeah are you sure
you're not thing that seem usually cuz I
know he's the one who said his mother
got no no no that by K god I'd beat the
[ __ ] out Coach K if you made my mom cry
imagine it she was on her knees crying
apologizing to him cuz she was she can't
he wasn't playing Sammy Ola who
transferred to SMU and played really
well yeah and okay saw and she came in I
would not say that well she saw came in
it's a little he's been to two Final
Fours since 2004 the last 15 years
hey Sox that's it Jeter - he's cheating
listen I didn't dad I did not grow up a
coach gay fan I I was always Pitino over
Coach K like as a kid like I really
didn't have and that and that's part of
the thing I think with college
basketball says we get older we don't
follow it as much as we used to college
bass yeah yeah yeah yeah like I remember
I liked it more in football you a
college basketball I like tell me why
large band classic you get into the Maui
class I did in my life but you'll never
see in college football at Texas Tech
playing for the championship game no but
it's never gonna happen
every year you're gonna have a team that
come kind of slowly comes out of nowhere
like the chief it's rigged and gets hot
and puts their team together and they're
Lumet
like the Chiefs last year Chiefs NFL
yeah we're talking NCAA here are y'all
talk about you but I know as you said
I'm going more than football why like
college basketball / college full /
college because you have a chance of a
team-high no we're yeah having a chance
to win even though Virginia is like all
the ACC they're not better now no the
player
in 38 teams it should shape Iain I think
they're gonna yeah they're gonna do
what's going on is these tea these these
conferences like this SEC ACC Big Ten
big 12 they're fighting it because it
makes it harder for their teams to get
there when they have to go up against
more teams and then the one then the
[ __ ] talent gets spread around cuz
you don't have to go these one or two
teams get let's be honest it's all about
the money it's all about the money and
it's all about like you you know the
Rose Bowl needs to be involved you know
the Orange Bowl needs to be involved you
know the Sugar Bowl needs to be involved
and whatever Jerry Bowl you know happens
in the just dumped system so those you
know granddaddy of them all the Rose
Bowl your sugar bowls they need to be in
there so it needs to be spread out in a
way that you know you bring in your
cotton bolls you bring in there but you
don't lose that tradition but you add
the name on it because the money is
where you're locking everything Dom yeah
I think you expand it and then give to
team to buy that's how that works guys
hear me out full 64 teams that would be
that man I was looking whole arias half
a season and then full 64 team
tournament do you okay you got my vote
yeah I mean goddamn you solved it it's
basically the team with any players left
well yeah yeah and the third string
quarterback
some guy just walked on could throw the
ball no I hear you about college
football though in the fact that like if
you lose a game you know past like your
third or fourth game it's all you're
probably gonna be out yeah of the
playoff unless you're like in the SEC or
you know it YB if you're alabama they'll
find an excuse to get you into the final
four or notre dame losses but look who
they play yeah come on we gotta get a
man I just I can't think what Notre Dame
kills me every year they're near the
time dude I mean telling me that Coach K
gets all these top [ __ ] picks and he
doesn't pay them how many years in a row
is this guy get a top pick white so
[ __ ] Illinois state gets nailed for
getting some [ __ ] guy who wouldn't
even make Duke and they [ __ ] they nail
him for cheating we got LSU getting bus
Arizona gettin busted you know these big
[ __ ] but coach gay
nobody's investigating this right I mean
did you see the headlights Duke is
looking into these allegations
why is Duke looking into allegations why
is the FBI who should be even doing
[ __ ] college sports investigation why
aren't they looking into it they're
looking at everybody else they're
nailing Louisville but why is it [ __ ]
ESPN or [ __ ] the FBI investigating
this cuz they all need Dukes [ __ ]
goddamn brand to get [ __ ] ratings it's
[ __ ] he's getting all the good
players and it's cheating [ __ ] you
I'm bored mad about that I don't even
care they paid me play payers play paint
players dude I don't give a [ __ ] but
stop [ __ ] going after sub schools and
not going after authors it's stupid
do you remember he doesn't get mad and
he did not break headphones no football
head people go down code yeah we got
paid no investigation you're gonna be
Dukes courtside fan of the game for I
dude I used to like Coach K and then
realize he's just a patton oswalt [ __ ]
sports where he's just like a [ __ ]
male feminist who talks a lot and behind
the scenes a [ __ ] scumbag can you
imagine if they miss a heart attack this
is me off can you imagine if they
investigated real crimes that way where
they decide the person who could who's
accused of the crime investigated oh I'm
gonna OD children I'm gonna check out
this murder don't worry well it's just
[ __ ] maybe think he's got all these
players three other top four guys cuz
they just want to be barred that Duke
tradition well now to be fair he did get
an unfair advantage with the USA
basketball job yeah that was a big leg
up and he knew what he was doing he knew
do you think that is enough no no no
like yeah that's his odds are going to
these camps now he's got around he's
he's on on the ground floor before a lot
of these recruiters and coaches are
wouldn't you think that if you're going
to these camps every summer and
well it's just gives it solace it's yes
so he's sticking that he's pay it's the
shoe companies that are following the
money to the kids and their families
learning that now oh yeah I think that
gives me is that the kids are making all
the money obviously but the shoe deals
are with the coaches I hope he's a
[ __ ] choose Coach K you know what I
mean it's just such a if you had to
explain it to someone who had no
familiarity with the system it wouldn't
make any sense that the coaches have the
shoe deals it's just like guys get all
the yeah it's a moderate plan thing
right it's like it's just complete your
flashlight is on again how does it I
like it off what happens if that burns
out do we know is I'm never I don't know
I think they found like yeah I think
they've dollars for I read every night
with mine like I use its gonna die yeah
I really think what are you your dad you
got a five-year-old five Nicole four
years what it is an iPhone at least it's
an iPhone we gotta get our Lantern well
oh you broke some news to me when you
walked in UCLA's new coach yeah the guy
from cincy what's his name Momo Jones
Momo Joe so Rick Rick Barnes pulls away
he gets he gets paid from Tennessee uh
everybody now gets paid from from unike
you know so funny dude
like the UCLA job was like LA for a
football state and have you seen SC's
recruiting class they're number two next
year
whoa USC's basketball USC yes they are
dude like he should have been the UCLA
coach inside the infield and Andy and
him and his hot-ass wife that's probably
half the thing hey do you come play me
you can run a train on my wife you want
to show her his own hey look at the
Google recommended searches and en
filled
and Ian filled wife yeah yeah yeah look
at her yeah I did
yeah boom yeah and their kids like yeah
I got super pair I think he's
overachieving a little bit there
he's like a Wall Street guy though right
wasn't that yeah and quitting they
became a coach he's a numbers guy
Florida Gulf Coast like that but no but
if I was UCLA why wouldn't you try to
get beard or Bennett from that last
night I panicked they did my god honest
truth they panicked they should have
waited over about they went through so
many guys huh yeah but do they try to
defend us I'm gone here we are if he
could speak until after well I think I
mean through his agent I think it that's
that was what that was my impression of
what is sensei's offense like Johnny
Cronshaw said they played I mean they're
more of a defensive focus teaming their
back to Ben Howland
he's a helluva cosa Mike Cronin I mean
he he's done really well in his career
welp dude you know you remember you USC
when they were going fight a football
coach who's their seventh pick at Oh
Jerome know the [ __ ] what's-his-face
who's the coach is Seattle right now
P Carol yeah yeah and he ended up being
a dynasty but if you look at to what you
eat USC did football wise to remember
they screwed her out Eidos around for
years and now he's he's at Auburn yummy
oh shoot yeah he's a great coach yeah no
yeah I mean these he only job
it's sexy but again a lot of these kids
don't know what that
yeah the sexy is you know and they
haven't made the final four since the
Russell Westbrook Kevin loved it doesn't
matter dude the Russell Westbrook is a
[ __ ] ambient here's what I hired
that's a class where they hired him UCLA
he kicked their ass by 30 this year
that's have you ever seen that Doc
Rivers like would hire he would sign any
player whooped asana you see that all
the time and that it's so funny we had
head coaches South Carolina would have
been interests
thing that guys he's a head case it's
crazy they'll rise a head case yeah for
sure
why don't they go after births pearl
he's a lunatic but yeah well he's guys
he's got and he can coach and he's kind
of personality he will you know what
he's just trying to do beat Coach K and
give [ __ ] players by paying for that
yeah he can't row for lying though and
it was his assistant I think who really
got in trouble yeah it's always insist
that Houston I would like that guy he's
got problems too but or Wichita Sampson
yeah
Wichita State would be okay Marshall
yeah I like him Greg Marshall that would
have been it was it was either Mick
Cronin or Greg Marshall those were the
guys I was down to what [ __ ] former
UCLA player Earl Watson no coach the
sun's briefly the worst coach I've ever
seen that's bull did you see Magic
Johnson dude they lasted 10 games and
they got rid of them it was so bad dude
dude I'm gonna tell you something I've
been a clipper fan for over 20 years
dude the Phoenix Suns right now are
literally the worst basketball I've ever
seen in my life
especially last year Houston versus
[ __ ] the Suns is the worst basketball
I've ever seen televise it looked like
rec league [ __ ] no defense nobody's
running anything look at their owner I
playing on the college basketball theme
how many like like Pam's or Betsy's or
like Doug's one their office pool today
that didn't even know what this was what
do you mean there's so many people that
win these office pools based on you know
mascots
yeah or you know it I don't know if
anyone got this one who is in Texas Tech
versus Virginia now it was I think it
was like a point five of the ESPN
browser some guys just got software it
just cranks out 90 million different
variations yeah and they didn't still
didn't get this this is they're the only
people who got this worse were people
who went to undergrad at Virginia and
went to grad school at Texas Tech you
know I'm like oh I put my two favorite
yeah
yeah that's all remember bottom night
coach there and he's like ah he can't
get the players here the way this guy's
been there three years and he takes on
the Final Four
pretty impressive you you know be coach
heard Bob Knight's kind of it's going a
little bit yeah
I heard them talking about Indiana day
he went watch the game oh did he
I didn't see that like wow he's like
he's harmless and he just throws a chair
he's had PS PTSD well if that's the
thing that they always want you to do
you know how they always like you're
known for something come on do it
throwing chairs I love that [ __ ] dude
that's how I would have coached man I
would have been I got it okay
there is a little third world dictator
knew I could tell what you sure scorch
the earth well I would definitely get
teed up a lot for sure I get kicked out
you should coach Little League and just
scream I have good coach baseball
I want coach Little League people let me
yeah I'll have a kid just don't cover
y'all conspiracies you'll be good
goddamn loser people they do background
checks oh really
yeah I didn't fir a why a so I coached
soccer now looking you know were you
good at soccer
I was decent when I was younger but I
mean I was coaching five-year-olds you
know and all these like herding cats
right basically yes they run to one side
and then they start you know some of
them will just all around a ball picked
up pick up grass you know I'm dead
serious and then you tell them which way
to run half the time and if they go out
of bounds they might end up you know
over these wins am i yep possibly it's
it's it's insane it's when I was that
age I played contact football and what
big part of the drill I I mean I I was
yeah like nine and we had this drill
where everybody is in a circle and you
just smash your helmets head to head in
each other for about an hour
[Laughter]
we had such violence in my high school
after that too is cause all the kids
play by gym coach used to have us do
Fight Club he would just be like okay
circle rock triple you Oh PJ free go go
we had a we had a gym coach right and he
didn't really know how to plan a day so
he made up this game called zoom where
everybody just stood
a circle and turned to the person to the
left and said the word zooming for 30
minutes we would just turn to the left
and smoke the cigarette and then I had I
in the same school I had a gym coach who
would did you ever do the thing where
you lifted the parachute oh yeah okay
well we sat inside and then he would
come out with this werewolf mask
horrifying I'm talking about five six
seven year old kids
scare and we would be terrified crying
and their different coach he's like I'm
different coach yeah same school
different for my blind date tonight
like if somebody was doing that my kid
now I kick ass a teacher fed a puppy to
a turtle in front of what what the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] wasn't alive I'd understand
if it was alive it was okay what circle
of life
I loved the first two week first two
rounds and then it starts losing a
little bit about your videos snapping
turtle why do you bring up cuz then I
want to see okay I don't want to see I
just have questions she was acquitted he
he was acquitted holy [ __ ] look at that
turtle that looks like something from
Jurassic Park Erin the turtle is now I
need to see how small the puppy is
smarter in judgment I want to know what
school do not center yeah goodness the
witness said Crossland dropped the puppy
into a tank where the turtle killed and
what is that teaching the circle of life
[Laughter]
first way already first tried to feed
the living puppy to a large snake why a
puppy like
why a pop this guy just wanted to
[ __ ] kill Bob why is everybody in the
crowd guys good oh dude that'd be like
hey [ __ ] dude their kids in kitchen
I'll fight it I'll fight them there is
that what scholarship some media tell
him I want to fight them find boys so
should we go by name find them on social
media
Robert oh [ __ ] talk about making a
difference in a kid's life let's see
okay I won't fight you just feed a tree
disable to a giant turtle that's getting
destroyed you know after Harambee they
don't people don't take this [ __ ]
lightly yeah yeah yeah coke hashtag them
tell me whoa whoa down there Robert
cloud that could be anybody we don't
want to both tell him I won't fight him
- that could be an insurance salesman
from Idaho guys he's already suffering
lives in Idaho I'm gonna [ __ ] yank
that dude you'll kill him
I know it looks pieces dude is there any
way that guy's got a child molesting
serious something wrong is something
sure hey let's play the puppy shall we
kid hey kids father get my tanning pedal
if you're not into the Book of Mormon
you're gonna burn like this puppy look
at that huh that's like some Game of
Thrones [ __ ] the tan on that man is by
the way that's it he's committed to
something like yeah these committee
really isn't committing felonies that's
like some Lannister [ __ ] man really oh
dude this Sunday are you excited of
course I'm excited yes let's do it kind
of bittersweet
where it's like you're excited for but
you know every time it ends that's six
episodes that's one less of them and
then we're getting to the end six weeks
we're done forever are you sad about
that well they're gonna have spin-offs
but yeah I'm sad sure they're gonna have
spin-offs that's the key do you think
HBO's gonna continue to do that kind of
production all right well there's a big
thing in the news now that this is kind
of the last big monoculture event is
what they'd like the last show that
we'll all watch together and then after
now it's just gonna be binge watching
you watch it whenever it comes out I can
see that that's not because what's big
is Game of Thrones nobody there's
nothing that everybody's like oh [ __ ]
it's appointment TV we have my favorite
thing is watching black people talk
about Game of Thrones
and they're just like why do people like
why oh why is this interesting
that's that's interesting you bring it
up though that probably it probably is
one of those last shows even though I
again on sports you're gonna I've never
watched Game of Thrones like what is
wrong with you yeah there's I've already
party yah he was like yeah I mean famous
right that's great you should do it
it's a lot and that's part of the binge
issue I have is I like to know what I'm
getting into and Geney sexually yes I
don't want any people you know jumping
through window yeah yeah yeah and I live
behind a sex sex store Romantics on
Lankershim and I dude they're lazy lazy
scene dude nothing getting weird number
one number one without no power ranked
at number three okay number number three
is the old rich guy yeah park his car on
the side of our street
yeah and walk over cuz he doesn't want
that Mercedes yeah or that Adi in that
parking lot
yeah when things go down yeah now also
to number two number two when things
fall down they don't pick them up it's
fair game I'm walking in the alley again
walking my dog not alley hopping yeah
and boom bag falls down giant black dawn
giant black don't drop the black god no
I I'm walking down I see an individual
bag breaks black dong there it is
probably paid a good 3044 giant blob a
picture that's not a quad they just walk
away walked away so in fares he was so
embarrassed by you all the time stuff
like this happens all the time like and
then you already saw just pick up your
Dylan go easy you random couples are
accepting it - I see random couples
going I saw a guy before a Dallas
Cowboys fan and I'm an Eagles fan so I
loved it going to romantics before a
cowboy game I'm like doing a Jerry's way
baby yeah yeah you know but yeah
how about them Cowboys that's exactly
the way he finishes yeah I could talk
about this all day this is what a great
place to live just lurk out your window
you know you just you get this mix match
of like you have some homeless people
that will try to go in beg and a they
haven't gone after me so I guess I lose
but just I like the different variations
of people that go in there yeah that is
the main thing that like you'll have
couples you'll have the cowboy guy the
old guy thing I think is amazing because
it's like you know they're doing some
you know what makes me sad is like them
I look at these old guys and I'm like so
I never get over this I'm always gonna
get laid and even as I'm getting
unfuckable I'm still yourself trying to
[ __ ] hit it yeah it makes me sad the
idea of going to a sex shop too I really
I I applaud that because we could get
anything on Amazon you could get
anything you know what I mean it's
they're making an appointment like I I
always say to our generation like I miss
going to Blockbuster because it was a
thing yeah I miss going to the record
store because there's a thing these
people their thing is getting freaking
dongs yeah you know for them good make
it a thing they're going there they're
you know they're can you buy dongs on
Amazon oh yeah you can look up horse dog
see if you can find a horse dog they
might doubt I mean horse I went in there
for white elephant look it up I went in
there for a white elephant went to the
lady said okay I have $30 I gotta win
this goddamn white elephant what so what
do I do look at that you can get a horse
dog I'm gonna get you that for Christmas
I can handle that you'll get a horse
[ __ ] Wow get you the big one that's what
good that's gotta be for gay dudes
mostly right there that are in there
like to know who knows who knows you
know yeah they open up
you know door to the universe you never
know what's gonna happen I'm doing
kegels like that disturbed why like my
vagina is gonna blow out of my that
would go and what they do is they got
this new system where they they they
just basically put a string around your
vagina and then you could just pull it
like a crown really like a Crown Royal
bag was like a bad Indiana Jones trap
this is my other favorite thing about
him he teaches me everything about bass
under every and what they leave the
strings are the based on the man you
okay so let's get into the two things
you want to talk about we're gonna get
in some this section of the show is
brought to you by bet Diaz I bet the
aside for all your betting needs go to
bet dias I use the promo code punch 25
and you'll get AA $25 bet in cash and
they will they will match any don't
deposit you make up to $500 that's great
yeah do we did you bet on the on the
tournament at all here we go so I I've
been doing that my other personality is
jackster Thomas I've got to crystal
balls I can see into the future
basically I'm gonna teach you guys a
little thing this is the best time to
get into the betting game degenerates
you know casuals it's about the spring
spring is in the air
alright so is the NBA playoffs yeah okay
I'm gonna let you sing it I'm gonna let
all of your gamblers go to there's this
site and let them know how to make money
on them this weekend Game one I wish you
like shady game water glass I would next
time next time I'm bringing my crystal
balls and I'm getting a hat yeah okay
I didn't have time yes I'm gonna do that
I'm not cousin Sal I'm jackster Thomas I
and Baxter Thomas is gonna tell you NBA
playoffs this week game ones game ones
all the unders all the unders Vegas has
not adjusted okay
so you're able to get on those lines
based off the regular you saying that
why am I the game slows down the game
slows down the playoffs you have two
teams that are gonna be gets each other
for pop maybe two weeks and Vegas has
not adjusted yet there's an NFL one
we'll get to later come and FL time but
this is the easy one so you're gonna
sleep here until the NFL season no no
cuz I'll come back for the NBA playoff
[ __ ] through it so that's my thing
find a number of game ones just Bethy
unders back the unders and live on that
live off the unders on all day one
series another thing I want to I want to
look at it against the Warriors yes
because they'll blow someone out first
game boom so that's what you're thinking
one they're adjusted higher because
we've had such a crazy season in the NBA
with with scores in general Vegas is not
on top of it so go to your website it's
a quick look for you and make and make
that happen also if you're trying to bet
any favorites in the playoffs again we
don't know who's matching up right live
gambling is something you probably want
to do once one of the favorites gets
down speaking of a gambling please up
this show Brian right bad good morning
sunshine hi Brian off is Patrick Brian
this is uh Mike Jacqueline this is Brian
red band we're doing here knocking
numbers here yeah we're talking we got
number band here uh first of all and
we'll get right back to this
congratulations on your sold-out show
last night the energy in the room is
amazing it was it was fun man it was
really good it's watching the scent of a
kill tony has been amazing to watch and
i you deserve it you've launched so many
podcasts and it's good to see that yours
is like going on selling out everywhere
man yeah it's great man i am blessed
we're about to do this huge tour also so
it's it's that helps a lot yeah yeah
it's a traveling freak circus yeah
that's great it's great are you excited
about and being playoffs to talk about
what number
yeah and you know I'm not ready all
right so go vote so we got that's the
unders on the first first game's first
game unders and then we're looking at if
if one of the favorites is down in the
game go do they have a live bet
mechanism right oh yeah yeah go get that
team that you like at that price another
thing I love about this weekend it's the
Masters weekend yeah okay I know I'm
that guy but I made 550 bucks off a $10
Patrick Reed 550 bucks from $10 I had
two of the majors last year on what I
call the lunch money bet what do you
have them for lunch thing ah probably
some sort of Armenian food how much is
that gonna run you probably Bob about 13
14 okay well so lunch money back yeah
you could you could have that and just
you know take your frickin nose Ivo numb
red Beaulieu bed yeah and do a lunch
money back yeah there's some very very
good guys to target talk to us okay stay
away from tiger stay away from Tommy
away from Tiger less you're Waffle House
waitress okay stay away from Rory
those are lot of money going there if
you're gonna go near to some of the
favorites I'm a big fan of Justin Thomas
yeah I won the PGA yeah you could put a
ten on him right right one 180 a hundred
which one's banging Wayne Gretzky's hot
daughter Oh Dustin Johnson he's a
favorite too I don't like them I almost
lost a lot of sack and he's long you
know on the course not a big fan of him
I like Justin Thomas and John ROM as
loose favorites right there I know any
powerful Indians will have the great
Indian golfers well I mean you could go
get Louie ah stakin Oh +4000 and I do
like that a lot he also put +4000 - yeah
those are - to to kind of target there
in that second range I'm a big fan of
Tommy Fleetwood he's got on the verge
again ten bucks
will win you 250 yeah one hundred twenty
five hundred it's the lunch money back
lunch money you look at the lunch money
bet for any type of like golf early with
like if you would have done Texas Tech
yeah per se is it lunch my wanted to
that would have paid yeah so those are
some things that jackster Thomas likes
to look into a
and the live gambling is you all send us
some of your picks and we'll post them
yes and but the main thing is again with
this weekend with the NBA playoffs first
game unders Vegas has not adjusted so we
heard of here Vegas now just the first
game understand okay what's what so
sports man thinking are we talking that
your sponsor yourself all your bad god
it was the same one yeah yeah yeah I was
you know I love Betty DSi yeah yeah yeah
did you but out speaking of bedding talk
I mean I would never bet that Lonzo ball
signed with CAA oh really I mean that's
what were you thinking will William
Morris more of a WM guy would sign of
clutch yeah I think that was living a
life ya thought that why maybe they
don't want him there next year so why
would you sign with clutch like you're
gonna end up in Charlotte well I'm happy
for him because that kids a great player
and his dad [ __ ] him and I'm happy
that I got to get took his own [ __ ]
the rails and and is controlling his
career that kids good he's if I'm the
right team he's gonna kill it yeah he's
good that's GA is better than him
I think SGA is good too but I think
Alonso ball is good
he's more traditional right BAM what's
getting you excited in sports right now
oh geez
so much stuff I so much probably can't
focus with just working this giant thing
you have going I just woke up honestly
five minutes I did I did the old eyes
snooze and like why why I set my alarm
for and they're like sleeping again and
I'm like wait a second had something to
do what a great life you live when you
sleep till noon dude that's early what
are you talking about time to use like
sleep till well last night I was up
pretty late
doing what
watching Japanese anime I got a facial
what does that mean some beat off in
your face no I got I do it nightly I
think with like the oils and stuff and
the things under your eyes and like the
lotion stuff my girls big-time yeah it's
like she goes to Ulta or wherever face
care yeah yeah it's great Sunday night
it's like pamper yourself day yeah okay
you don't you don't do anything to
pamper yourself no dude I'm just
naturally [ __ ] smoking yeah there's
these great things you buy on Amazon
these gold collagen little things for
your eyes and it feels good you put them
on and it helps with like whole red band
a cosmetic line if that one cosmetics go
in a Middletown America and say [ __ ] it
it is cool yeah uh-huh it is cool to be
fou-fou face that's your face yeah you
brush your teeth but you have your mouth
half shut half at the time you know but
your face is holy always dude for sure
clean your face off man yeah be a man to
have a clean face nothing wrong being
shiny you you have somebody come to your
house to cut your hair which i think is
amazing no no I I go to my I hear I've
been I have this one here stylist right
and wherever she cuts here I follow her
on cuz she she goes places like we want
to go full-time just like [ __ ] you and
she moves on so now I just go to her
hair her house is you cut to my hair but
she lives in like Englewood have you
been the Inglewood lately yeah not on
purpose really not well that's really
nice oh they other stadiums really dude
you go down the houses are [ __ ] nice
today with when they call it white
stormed it no education oh yeah yeah I
thought that was yeah I'm a black he'll
get so mad they're like yeah [ __ ] you
jet you mean we're cleaning it up and
it's nice and nobody's getting shot at
nice how are you saying so we're saying
white everybody get quiet on that okay
yeah I've only been here 10 minutes I'm
gonna get kicked off red band I'm out
what else is going on
I also bought your Tesla dude oh yeah
God just got a Tesla that's badass are
you just loving it it's it's really is
it does it drive itself it does drive
itself and it helped me a lot last night
[Music]
I know it's great no it's really cool it
it's so neat because you know you buy a
car you know after a couple years it
starts feeling outdated right this car
weights like once a month or so you can
an update and it just gives you a new
feature in it it keeps it fresh like
there's this new one I fall yeah it's
exactly like it like I just got this
thing called dashcam where it makes a
dash cam out of all the cameras that are
on your car so like if you get in a car
accident you just push a button and it
saves the last 10 minutes of your ride
and so it's constantly recording what is
this Russian bids have you ever watched
Russian vids oh definitely there's so
many times because insurance guys people
chatting in crashes so you have to have
webcams right yeah and it happens a lot
of time people like jump on your hood
and like act like you hit them this has
not only the front camera but has the
two side cameras so it's great and it's
got this new thing called century mode
where if you park your car and anyone
gets near a car it turns on the big
screen that's in the in the in the Tesla
it says hey you're being recorded right
now and it has how from you know the red
dot how yeah and it records odd all the
cameras so if somebody's trying to break
in your card not only are they like OSHA
and being recorded but it also sends you
like an alert like hey you're being
reported
oh yeah yeah see this woman's getting
out of her car and behind her like her
but you could see her reach back and key
this guy's car some people just hate
Tesla and but she's with her kids so
while she's putting her kids in the car
she's reaching back and keying this car
so this century mode that they just
updated with not only did they the guys
see this
I this woman got arrested this mom got
arrested because of this new mode and
this was like just updated [ __ ] mom
single my wouldn't do that
shirt by the way I just said that's
weird that was like why is she doing
that that's all of these crimes of like
people stealing breaking into cars or
stealing cars in general it's all
backfired like you're you're screwed now
you're there's no way you're you're
gonna be on camera somewhere if you get
in that car freaking the eye in the sky
is gonna have you on the news in a
second yeah you know you're screwed
I've gotten away wind please chase hey
do you have cameras inside the car so
you're not gonna be porn
there is cameras inside but right now
there hasn't been an update to use those
cameras yet so but that's top shelf one
right you went big I with the SUV one
yes which just because the doors one
time speaking of Tiffany Haddish she was
on kill Tony last night she has one of
these cars and I was on the fence about
buying one and then one night she did
the dance thing where you can make it
dance on have you have you seen that she
calls up Beyonce mode test list have
this mode where yeah she has the same
one and you can make it dance where the
like the doors flop open and the side
mirrors start it looks like it's
possessed
anyway she did it once in the parking
lot of the comedy store and I was so
blown away by it that I was like that
night I drunkenly purchased it I was
like oh I get what a name to you next
morning I wake up my god cause do you
have who cares it's way more than like a
drunk Amazon purchase yeah I mean I go
and buy like t-shirt Jersey I know yeah
I walk and here you're buying cars okay
now what what is that you know everyone
at The Comedy Store Hawk Hawk sandwich
yeah it nothing weird is weird you guys
like grab each other's tits and stuff we
don't you girls do but not all Joe Biden
did this he wouldn't be
though the world would end okay nobody
has done that wait no now now all right
what do you guys think about it because
you know I get like like you know he's
such a interesting person where you know
he's like you know holding girls and
like smelling their it's creeper he has
a little creeper but I mean it's also
using an innocence you know like like I
have I had a gland creeper
grandfather that you know you just give
you a big hug any kid he loved kids but
not in that way you know but no it's in
that and that's the problem is I feel
like we're stuck in this place of like
he offended them he's he's an old man
that is been passionate like yeah you
can call him a pig on to breaking law
right like inviting people back is
[ __ ] do you see that way like just
straight up hold the baby like crotch
you agree though ready yeah I agree
are you going to read banned for
political tags I get it it's say you
could look at anything like especially
how they slow it down in the news that
they're showing her do you have any
videos of the tesla's dancing oh yeah
yeah you could if you type in Tesla
dance dancing Tesla there we go
so this is what a Easter eggs there's a
lot of Easter eggs on here and this is a
WoW it's doing the commercial you can
also do it's so weird you guys can
afford you as a youtube premium here
right so you skip the commercials it's
like 9 bucks a month maybe but if you
turn on the another sound but you it
also has a song that a place and it
starts flashing its lights and and doing
all this [ __ ] and then once like halfway
through this I it will start opening its
doors and dancing
this looks like a bird mating [ __ ]
dance
yeah please get out of my dreams get
into my car
the scam is this when the robots come to
kill us
yeah yeah so I saw this in the parking
lot
Tiffany was dancing and she kept on
calling her Beyonce mode and thanking
Tyler Perry yeah but it's it's fun to do
about it freaks people out too like that
like if you're in like a grocery store
parking lot and it starts then now if
the side mirrors start dancing and [ __ ]
like that and this is just an easter egg
another one is like they have the
whoopee cushion mode where you can put a
whoopee cushion a virtual whoopee
cushion on any of the seats if somebody
sits in a go you like it it's a tort you
can have the turn signal become farts
and so there's a red band that works at
Tesco yeah his name's Elon Musk he's but
you'll never see Ford have it oh we went
to a dance mode on her Ford Explorer no
like this is like everybody NorCal has
Tesla there's just every well it's it's
grown pretty everywhere I love it more
please more it's [ __ ] great and it's
really great because like if you go to
Whole Foods or like the mall you get to
charge your Tesla for free or any
electric car and you always get like the
best parking spot so it's like the
handicapped spots you always see the
spots like save for an electric vehicle
well now I get to park there and you
don't have to find parking it's always
like a handicap stall you imagine if you
are a handicapped person with a Tesla
you could park in the store you wouldn't
even have to hey probably that's it
that's that Tesla probably comes with a
jetpack or something we're almost
[ __ ] transformers that's almost
bumblebee right yeah and it's great
because you know the the most popular
newest Tesla is only 35,000 and then you
get some tax breaks like five or
somebody it's faster like that can beat
a Lamborghini like like it's one of the
fastest cars and that's not even one of
the faster cars if you type in Tesla
versus you'll see Porsches Lamborghinis
and [ __ ] like that like the model 3 when
I'm talking about that means everyone
sees he got that yeah yeah you but it
doesn't have as long of a charge huh uh
it has a it like MA
as 310 miles for the model 3 so yeah
it's pretty long can i buy it so it gets
as much as you do like yours huh can i
buy the cheap one but with an upgrade of
like super long battery yeah yeah you
could buy it with super long battery or
super fast so this one I think is one of
the only cars that he doesn't be the one
that you chose but boy it gets close
look at it yeah and hey lucky you're
thinking an SUV versus the Lamborghini
it can't even become close but this
one's actually close my car does like 0
to 60 and like I think for seconds or by
the way I can every guy that owns that
car looks like that am i right dude have
you ever seen that car pool and that's
you like always Apple and trailer and
bro Jay Leno or Jay Leno but yeah it's
pretty ridiculous like how fast these
cars are dude middle Easterns love Lambo
sproutin and they love it when it has
like metal green dude right I tell you I
saw a cop a bike cop trying to pull over
a Maserati the other day it was so
[ __ ] funny and the and the guy
driving it was laughing and he saw me
laughing and they had a sec dude like do
we wanna go kick the [ __ ] out of this
guy we're trying to pull this car over
and they're gonna get him no I mean they
probably got the license so eventually
they're gonna get them do that
Lamborghini avid InterVarsity hari not
the one below I'm sorry is that if race
I guess not who cares anyways you can
find it now when you're driving do the
ladies in LA stare at you going who's
driving that tesla l lays a little
different because so many people i've
noticed once you have a Tesla you
realize that there's so many Tesla's out
here you just don't notice something to
you yeah yeah you open your eyes but no
it's it's what's really shitty yeah holy
[ __ ]
like it took off on then the Tesla's the
oval racing boom yeah yeah because it's
instant on there's no gears other
it's just like on or off there's one
gear so the it what's crazy is it bugs
all these people have these like
$200,000 cars you know but it's great
I mean ERDs went again dude the Nerds
went again always when they're about oh
they're about to release this roadster
and if you type in like Tesla Jay Leno
this new roadster is so [ __ ] fast and
the Jay Lynn takes a ride for you know
Jay Leno is a car guy like gas head I
might have worked on this I worked on a
few worked with cool and I think this
was I think this was last season they
shot this yeah now this one near the
middle and yeah around there
oh is that that's it it's like a Porsche
looking yeah a Porsche Boxster right
yeah yeah what do you think that's gonna
run I think this is $200,000 yeah listen
we know you don't want all the peasants
like here you go
but look how fast that I don't know if
he already we took a ride for it there's
a part where he takes a ride for it and
it's it's it feels like you're on a
roller coaster like because it's just
instant on power it takes the breath out
of you how long till Rogen has one of
these yeah in the steering wheel oh I'm
sure he's already pre-ordered in a
steering wheel it looks like something
from like a video game look at that
little like Tron or something like hey
how many was that
how many cars is Rogen at about five or
six look it's like it's so fast man this
is this is going to be the funnest
you're gonna see this car all over the
place inside blowing up blowing up
Tesla's have known to blow up now ya
know confuse with Samsung phones yeah
there might there might be one or two
but there's a their own video I know
that kind of is like that there was a
video somebody filming a Tesla on the
side of the road on fire where it like
got in an accident or something like
that but it's not really a known thing
yeah they were actually super safe it's
a logo did I ask
even in the logo he has this phone
working
Jack can take off yeah it's that time
its acupuncture yeah are you gonna get
some acupuncture hoping I'm doing it Oh
cupping I can't do i watch the
chiropractor for the first time
yesterday that was something you know
I've always wanted to go but then I've
heard that it's kind of iffy if it even
like helps you and if you don't go to a
good one you can [ __ ] yourself up they
could [ __ ] you up I don't know that's
the station people in general pseudo
exactly they can [ __ ] you up yeah if you
don't go to a good one look at that look
at this cross grabbing [ __ ] it's
a baby what do you think he's gonna yell
good to see this baby that's a perfect
example of baby super Cree and I also
love it by the way his son yeah he's
never gonna get even close - princey
his son is so shady it's unbelievable
I listen Trump shady - I'm totally with
you on that but they're all flawed you
one thing this presidents taught us if
you make a goddamn mistake
just [ __ ] go through it everyone's
calling
why should he apologize why should Biden
pologize for something that we brought
with me baby what this is a hideous baby
one is in good hands you're good baby
let's see that he's just you know this
is what they do in church like he's
doing shirt look I see the baby - Biden
be a Biden go fine I'm a baby let me
taste you baby
oh god is so he's a are you a Gerber go
enjoy your [ __ ] Oh welcome back to
the show the penalty box
ah Johnny Woodard everybody Johnny Weir
sorry babe you woke up really quickly by
the way huh like when you came in I
could tell you retire you like the drugs
kicked
what are you taking snorts matter you
like to crush it up and store I used to
do that like 12 years 15 years ago you
could get all your urges
does it really forget to better yeah
this guy stays up to like 7:00 in the
morning listening to his neighbors [ __ ]
I I do to me who told me that where
you're like your girlfriend away you may
that's your part that you know that's
it's called let's call the comedy show I
remember when I was a kid my neighbors
we lived in an apartment and the people
next to me would [ __ ] and as a kid I
would like try to listen you know get
the cups and stuff like that and then I
started like with an a screwdriver Spurs
[ __ ] no I started like trying to slowly
dig like I'm like a prisoner like in my
wall and like everything I'll hide it
behind this picture my mom would come in
what are you doing yeah and then like
when I would sleep I'd like pull it
aside and like dig more and then I hit
like a fire wall and I didn't know it
was a fire wall there's a hard part I
couldn't ever get through that part so I
started getting hard
the hole used to be like the size of a
baseball and then finally my mom saw all
the powder on the grounds like with my
son doing coke drywall did you end up
sticking your dick through that hole no
no I think you know I don't know how I
explained it either hey weirdo hi are
you from Columbus are you gonna oh dude
it's so Santoni I had Youngstown which
is it North youngstown shady dog yeah
yeah that's you know that's nothing
Italian it's clear Jay what do you know
stuff like that
dude Ohio outside of Columbus Klump yeah
is the shadiest it's like ghetto country
oh yeah absolutely
hood farmer a lot of farming yeah hood
farmers well I don't know hood Dayton
you ever been a date no no Dayton's got
straight-up like [ __ ] Bloods and
Cripps of [ __ ] ear of [ __ ] farming
teachers [ __ ] what on what their shame
they should I did a dating funnybone
once and I thought I was gonna get my
ass kicked bags again I had a nice Hugo
Boss jacket and I was just hanging out
this bar and he's I I just I was just
kind of looking down my phone look up
three dudes around me and they're just
go yeah nice jacket
huh well yeah I know what you give me
uh-huh I go give me that dumb watch he
goes oh this you couldn't afford this
[ __ ] what I did I'm like I'm about to
get wine just like yeah [ __ ] lynching
style yes she gonna come up and [ __ ]
stop your [ __ ] that's a crazy story yeah
yeah dating you've heard a long time
like I did a bit about being a strip
club with a woman of fake but and she
sits on my face and rides my face that
was dating like they're just it's
anything happens they fake asses by the
way they are the worst
it doesn't work when you go to your lady
meetings tell them we don't enjoy the
fake bond yeah you look like ninja
turtles hey there's a couple of Braille
with [ __ ] turtle shells I'm on your
side yeah if you're gonna do that try
the pants out first with that support
just to make sure they look good cause
you got your legs then just this turtle
shell yeah looking it up I like I like
good ass like a big asian chicks huh
know what's funny though is that I had
never appreciated a big ass you know
until as an adult but like looking back
my grandmother would have been the best
Instagram model ever because she had the
biggest ass in the world but that was
before the Sun
see that like that doesn't fit her body
it just doesn't look good doesn't 15h me
win ninja turtles good that's what that
[ __ ] looks like can you imagine and
like a huge it and that's not even a big
ass trying to find a good warez your
next kick we are in West not Nyack New
York this weekend
Thursday kill Tony and then comedy shows
all week so was it go like Tony heads
lines you feature and then then you do a
big like what an early show or Late Show
kill Tony we used to do a Late Show kill
Tony but then we are like that's
something our be early we used to do
early kill Tony's and then just stand up
but you can't it's hard to follow that
man cuz that's such a craziness and then
try to do stand-up comedy after that you
know we used to do two shows in a row
and usually everyone would stay for the
second show or by two yeah you got this
is the kind of ass I like look at this
girls I don't know if you know this girl
if you follow this exact real tits
that's not that's not like you know this
is Ali grace this woman has the craziest
boobs and if you follow her on Instagram
it's so funny she's like like Sunday
she's like at church and I'm like we're
late for church and she's just like you
could imagine her walking into the
church yeah it's crazy painful right
carrying around those boobs that's what
I would think how heavy those things
have to be look at that [ __ ] that I mean
that's just like no but - you're not
joking no I like a big bite but like I
definitely don't like this this list
this looks like a really bad Photoshop
is like I'm learning how to Photoshop
you're not getting your heads like heads
too small like it looks like something
from reddit right
so ugly I can't get over I can't get
over that that's even possible - in
Spanish you don't have stretch marks
although I don't know how how is that
even possible what's crazy at being a
guy of course you sat there like a
Wanderers in your naked pictures and so
I googled and the [ __ ] together is
there's some naked pictures I've heard
but look at these kids
I mean she's resting oh yes she's
resting her polishes throwback Thursday
see that looks way better yeah why I
like boobs like that make you look fat
when you're not fat like she's not fat
but she looks huge you got flat stomach
but this yeah
massive mammaries yeah my half-sister
has this boob disease like I forget
what's called where your boob at Titus
or what she was she was born with boobs
that big like this big like where I
think that's a disease no it really is
if you google boob oversized boob I
don't know Medical I'd have no idea but
like think she had to go to like Sears
and get brawls made for her like yeah
and she still has it to this day in the
gynecomastia yes and it couldn't record
they couldn't fix it because I forget
why that they you can't really fix it I
don't know why but this poor girl always
looked like she was fat growing up there
was just so much boob that they had to
you know strap it in so it just look
like this is this has got to be like
body dysmorphia right where you can't
see yourself yeah this is your face look
at her cheeks that's like cheek implants
nose job like it looks like a Jenga
tower you know or you just got some of
the bricks sticking out in the front
that really would have such bad back
issues how does she get on a goddamn
roller coaster I find to think look at
that I know and to think these boobs are
with a bra I want to see them just
unleashed like Kim Kardashian's got
nothing on her
yeah I would I would love to just [ __ ]
around like like an hour just get to
like do whatever what to her you know
what would you do like [ __ ] like sit
down on one of them and spin around in
circles like a kid like I don't know how
I'd be scared to pop him look him on the
left you know I would take them off one
on the Left more than the one on the
right
oh no they're perfectly round dude look
at that like ball like beach balls
they really do they're perfectly round
yeah stomach is fake I should paint in
my soccer balls for the world cover that
would be great and just hold it Mike
Mike she's like I got the balls guys I
mean for like a nap like it has to be
from the front we're just walking around
to see this yeah the reactions oh my god
what's like bigger like in a burka how
does she sleep don't worry about
swimming at least I just wanna see her
on a bird scooter I just want you on the
bird scooter because there are boobs
like she can't balance or fall in a
guy's like this is my dream oh look at
her friends is she Brazilian
that's a good question having no idea I
didn't I dunno I think she was at a
comedy show last night or two nights ago
us ever seen are you hug how do you hug
somebody like you had to bring em kind
of in the middle right yeah like one of
these things
that work bounce off your bounce off
heard you hit the wall and break your
neck like that is so funny that is fan
oh there's a lot her I have her fetus
family yeah I love that I have friends
mine who were so funny and had like two
friends okay you know how milk works
guess she nurse with her baby formula I
think those nipples are dead like kinda
but I don't know about that but that
like does it come with a milk I'm like
in the middle or she probably had her
nipples taken off and then put the boobs
in then put soda back you might have it
was like tattooed nipples or something
like a tattoo like fork look yeah look
at her kid how embarrassing is that for
that kid you know like that kid the
other kid was like that looks like a 12
year old kid not that one but the other
one you'd be like you don't have to come
the kid on the rights probably
masturbates so many times to his mom you
know like that's so unnatural yeah how
about these friends that come over she's
got like a [ __ ] Bible oh and she goes
to church the arms that's how I was like
the demons in the house those titties
are haunted maybe you need like the bad
she's in LA yeah he just said she'd loot
of course she was in LA look at her
where else would she live go maybe
she'll be on kill Tony pseudo you
shouldn't fight her to kill Tony you do
breaking breaking news from super fan
garnet
he is raising money for women for what
women kids yeah crowd funding for what
to get implants how's mom no they give
women tits what stop I really I mean I
don't have a problem with it it's like
look at the shape to me it's just as
dumb as face tattoos look she's like she
want to do it by the way when I give up
on any dream of ever doing a day job I
will get a neck tattoo really yeah I'm
[ __ ] I'm so done with tattoos now
your tattoos are probably one of my
favorite tattoos she has really good
tattoos but that's very rare very rare
I'm giving one right here in one right
here and I'm done yeah are you gonna get
thank you a chicken look at Ted Paul it
looks just like him is that what she
calls her vagina
Deadpool no God speaking of Alex Jones
can we talk about that yeah how was that
buddy
yeah how do you think it wow I think it
went fine okay I'll take it as I
expected he thinks I didn't press him I
pressed him on a lot of [ __ ] I knew
something you should have brought up
Alex Jones fart Cup I would love to hear
what he thinks about it now I only
didn't ask one question I wanted to ask
that was what was that hey god Julian
massage that's it I wish I could pressed
for time was he did you get the sense to
you trying to get the door
no what was that thing you saw my
somebody was outside yeah these guys
these door guys were shooting something
and they asked if he could just stand in
it and he really wanted that's nice I
would ask you he's a really nice guy
apologized hey do him so I'm late he's a
super great guy
and dude the beginning of the interview
he was kind of steamrolling me a little
bit and then at some point just stopped
and he was trying to gauge the room IANA
get it who is this guy I don't think he
knows Maya had to clarify my bathing
suit of Bert's stomach yeah it's weird
man it does look like Bert that looks
why would you wear a hair dye want to
see your on your mom's house oh my god
how great this thing I take a poop right
between her boobs
squish I'm gonna see you see what
happened it's like a plain enough funny
let's crowdsource that Oh God so is it
really into this though some guys huh
some guys are into that or open on girls
I mean both but I meant this like a
giant tooth have you seen the recent
busts of escorting in Los Angeles to
escort websites like the all the
high-end porn stars web sites you know
they also funnies they hate being called
hookers right they get so Matthew call
them a hooker but it's like you're
you're just doing your day job without a
camera right yeah I don't understand
like I have no problems reports that
we're all friends with a bunch of them
you know but it's kind of sad that
they're not in our likes anymore oh wow
naughty shows coming back is it frickin
gonna be downtown and I got a giant
promoter his job is to promote it all
and he wants me to do it in this
warehouse and we're gonna do it did Wow
that's when I used to get a lot of
response they said you can't have that
creepy guy that you hang out with I go
giant absolutely didn't say that do you
like nicer is one of the best things to
ever create you just got so excited
Johnny you actually fun I get here right
after all that stopped when I started
hanging out with him that's when like
naughty shows like big guys read ban
will remember the old improv days oh oh
yeah those were the best live shows ever
I will put that up against any show in
Los Angeles missed all the good stuff
you had that you had the news story
about the prostitution stings van nah it
was in Van Nuys and they show the
Madam's but what's crazy is that this
lasted so long and like they just caught
on to it they even where have been
paying taxes for like 20 years this
website why legal it's so does the next
it's the next frontier I think it's
gonna come down it should I mean like
the problem is you'll never get old
women to vote
to legalize prostitution but at the end
of the day it's like it's capitalism
yeah it's like supply and demand
it's and dude so prostitutes are going
to jail but sugar daters are like sugar
dating is just prostitution it's just
[ __ ] stupid real escorting you mean
escorting with cuddling they should they
should make it legal because you know to
make them get tested like porn stars at
least you know you're not spreading
diseases and [ __ ] make taxes so we you
know they get some money you know you
know how much new money if didn't we'd
made us money you know if they make
prostitution legal how much money the
city would have I think dude I think
dude if you tax to ass you you could fix
everything in this country I think I
know that one top left one two it's a
really Terrell it and Tonya Linfox or
what's-her-name yeah I should tell you
this website no better not now there's
this one website where it's all porn
stars and you could just pretty much
choose which one you want and I think
this is like Jodie Hoskins
she just looks very familiar like
everybody you see on bumble these are
probably four women arrested for
allegedly running an all-female high-end
prostitution ring that spanned three
states including there's a say the
website I want to know if this is the
website I knew about everything that
interview wasn't great I've ever done
say what lack blu-ray it's just it is it
is a tinfoil hat this week it's been
doing this show for two years and he
hates it what tinfoil hat yeah well I
could see why
only men who understand yeah I mean it's
it's alright you know we don't have to
do that but it's you know it's
conspiracies to me are fun and stuff but
when you take it too seriously it's just
kind of well I think right is that you
take everybody seriously even when
they're out of their [ __ ] minds well
I let them give people another set up
for you should hang themselves so you're
kind of the the impartial I let him talk
you let the fans decide whether he's
full of [ __ ] or not yeah and they mostly
are we know I love it when Samson
conspiracy mode and when he's not like
right now this is my favorite kind of
thing I know it's like what does that
schizo or not schizo whatever but the
other night I was just at the comedy
store and you were in you're one of your
modes
oh my guy started screaming at me like
what the [ __ ] he tried to do here at
least one thing we all just stopped
talking and he knows like vice-president
yeh touched me well yeah they were
losing it but I got back and you're
screaming right I wasn't even in the you
know it's hard to hear on the eldan and
in the basement when you're upstairs at
the comedy school I could hear them
screaming so and I got down there and
the first words I heard war Hillary
Clinton and then he touched me he bite
into you yeah the whole thing was about
what Hillary Clinton it wasn't me
they'll fight have to yeah you just said
to release it it's a conspiracy why you
haven't released it it would be it goes
all the way to the top everything's a
conspiracy [ __ ] rude how what are the
comments like on that pretty good right
war are you getting any like you're a
[ __ ] chauffeur
oh yeah that's all right no matter what
I do I'm Michelle I love that's the
that's the kind of you're playing with
fire right because you get the
psychotics
yeah for sure thank everything is but I
love it yeah dude I mean it's changed my
life
do you regret calling it tinfoil hat no
I actually I'm sure there's a problem
for you at the beginning there right I
love you you know had trouble booking
Phyllis but I it's the NWA it's like I
said what is the one word or phrase that
is so demonized and obviously
conspiracies but everyone's called
conspiracy something so it's like the
n-word okay that's one I'm like it's
tinfoil
I'm gonna call it tinfoil hat and just
cuz I just want to take it back and yeah
I love it I mean some people won't come
on because it's called tinfoil hat but
that's that stupid it's just dumb why I
mean but you it's mostly people who are
kind of they don't want to be dismissed
you know people with we've got yeah oh
what happened it's because we're talking
about 10 foil hat you're fine you
probably just kick the power thing on
them you can hear I camp I can hear you
fine you're great it's what happens when
you talk your conspiracies we get people
no no it's under it's by Johnny it's
it's Johnny did it was a power thing
Johnny [ __ ] [ __ ] there's a mic
sometimes I get weird around she I agree
like like like last night she at the
beginning of the show slapped me on the
side of the head hit me so hard in the
ear and of course I said everyone saw
that right because you know settlement
settlement I don't know man I mean you
yeah you obviously have some inkling of
well I'm incredible I have a real
problem with I don't want to bother
people it's like really freaks me out
it's like so when I feel like I even get
the inkling that somebody might be I
just get weird and I run off like I like
a good thing I can't talk like what
rogon who's like the nicest guy to me
if I think I'm bad I like
run off bill burr I can hey how's your
family and then run off and like Tiffany
I don't know why dudes it's like I just
felt like lately it's like she [ __ ]
mad at me for [ __ ] some reason so I
get like really weird
I've hate bothering people no that's
good though it's called self-awareness
it's burning up but it's I'm like
[ __ ] over the top like [ __ ] weird
about it
I get that with a few people burn I get
that way you just know what his life is
like right I mean it's just all people
yeah Marc Maron I feel that also I
always feel like I'm bothering Marc I
love Marc Maron that's part of his whole
personality though yeah which is crazy
because I feel like I'm the same as him
and we would be best friends but I have
this weird thing yeah you guys I mean
dude you're about your Merrin was really
good I I thought you did a good job
there that was cool you run Maron yeah
yeah yeah because when it first started
he's like dude I go hey man Congrats on
the [ __ ] podcast something's going
great it's like you want to do it I'm
like [ __ ] yeah goes okay call me
tomorrow we'll set up and then like
literally it just blew up and I never
heard from so then down the line he
started doing my shows and I'm just like
hey dude if you ever need buddy say oh
you haven't been on it okay so your turn
in the barrel and I'm like so I went
there and I go okay what are the stories
I know he would appreciate so I did all
my my best stories on there and I was
really did it what last year yeah I was
really like brutally honest like you
know about time I got robbed by I'm
trying to buy drugs and all that [ __ ]
and hooker writers yeah twice in the
same day it's so good that's so good I
know my hey when you got the [ __ ]
urge you got a go for it right so yeah
it was very happy with it I just haven't
been on a lot podcast lately it's really
weird man like I used to be on everybody
nobody asked me anymore because what
happens now you're gonna be on
infowars.com you go no they're always
like hey so talk about conspiracies I'm
like like come on I'm like okay and then
you go to comments [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
his kicks free I'm like dude I don't
want idea well I can talk about anything
for everybody
yeah but I don't want to talk about talk
about farting talk about [ __ ] big
tits McGee I could talk about anything
okay well you've been the porn guy you
kind of started now which is better
being the porn guy or the conspiracy yet
Oh conspiracy guy okay I would think so
I couldn't sell a ticket to the boy it's
not better for me which makes zero sense
to me like it should be it's like the
opposite you should be able to do that
because we go on the road
nobody wanted anybody from their town to
know they were at the porn show you know
conspiracies are fine cuz it's seven
basically just news you know so but porn
I mean like that should have been on
television and it just it was just at
the wrong time but this guy's I go
listen I'll do a show with you if you
promote I'm our guy what's the club that
you're doing
it's downtown so we're like we're gonna
get all the dancers where I'm like dude
I'll just [ __ ] what does that the place
where they do the stripper wrestling no
this thing's like this make sure there's
parking giant rapes and he wants to get
into common all right so it's like he's
like I want to do this I'm like okay
I'll get a nice suit on I'll wear my
glasses I've been to a few illegal like
clubs like bars talk to my things no no
it's just like people on ecstasy and
it's just like a house bar like they
have bartenders and everything and you
know and it's illegal as [ __ ] but the
problem with about those it's they're
always so fun but you never there's
nowhere to park so you're parking on the
street walking through like like the the
light of the living tag yeah I sell
alcohol I'm like yeah cuz everybody's on
ecstasy yeah nobody's drinking cuz
they're all doing yet everywhere just
drop anywhere where they're playing
that's the only way you can listen to
EDM is to be swimmin have a banded metal
because they like to drop E and watch
some dude with a marshmallow on his head
hit a cash register boss I love the day
guy has his own master class you know
what if marshmallow what's crazy is kids
love that [ __ ] like my nephews love
marshmallow like that is favor their
face I remember come out going dude
that's so smart
oh yeah well said just copy off a dead
now yeah but am I
smell oh so gray yeah wet the poop emoji
would be the biggest one like that's a
new character yeah that's your right and
there's no easy to remember I remember
the first time I found the fart sound
word on funny die dead what happened no
no I mean like nobody talks about how it
was because everything's on YouTube now
nobody want I mean they were trying to
have their own platform right and that
didn't really work so they move their
[ __ ] over to YouTube yeah and plus like
if you just do nerd [ __ ] you're not
gonna get everybody
you're good people over at Funny or Die
dude what do you think of the Joker
trailer I love it yeah this is my life
that's my life I said that made me laugh
like that is sam says he looks scary
he's scared thin man like really creepy
he's playing him walking Phoenix now
here we can can we look at that here
okay the trailer right I can't watch
well I I just want to look at I just
want to show you how creepy he looks so
we don't watch it what can't you watch
why Oh looks good yeah I want to see how
bad reviews but it looks good there's
this thing where he's I don't know on a
date or something with this beautiful
woman you as crazy as I stopped
following all this stupid DC [ __ ] but I
think I mean um doesn't look good stupid
I would have loved it when I was a kid
hey it's okay did it do well yeah it did
pretty well
good for DC they've been [ __ ] in the bed
there's no longer he's yeah I guess he
looks like a pretty good joke I think it
looks great but it looks like it's a
different story though yeah y'all hear
this look you see he's this that's the
hot chick yeah and he's look at him he's
just bleeding
it's like Brody's friend that was at the
memorial from oh yeah the guy with a
horse dick that did porn no no no no
Dana Dana Dana yeah
Tatum is a good guy had horse really is
he's like a guy dude I got big dick I
gotta do porn he like felt like it he
had to do it mm-hmm but he did really
well at the memorial to you I was kind
of your everyone did so great yeah it's
very a dude Yoshi Bob he's the only
person Bob at a [ __ ] memorial well
and then Brendan came on and ripped the
Sklar bricking rapid crush but Rick
Ingram did what Brian Holtzman mostly
does like that was literally Brian
Holtzman spheal yelling everybody how
phony they are for being there so when
Brian went up and did it they're like
you're like the second white guy in a
black room you ever done that where
you're like the first black guy crushes
second white guy gets a dick kicked in
there like okay we've already seen this
I'm not taking over our [ __ ] shows
well then there was a whole second part
of it right where I got pushed back to
[ __ ] like open mike floud level it
was anybody known for that see I watch
the stream yeah people stayed for it
dude I literally went up in front of 20
I literally did the Brody Stephen spot
really 20 [ __ ] people yeah I skip
that all that I was too emotional it's
like I'm good man well then I don't like
emotionally exhausting I I didn't want
to go up when I thought you know man
it's Brody so I'll go up you know I
didn't have much to say I didn't want to
say anything I just said two quick
things and then I got in and out [ __ ]
Nicky Youssef running the light like I
mean just going I'm like what are you
doing he had a really serious sort of
message do you I mean even for a
memorial it was heavy like what was his
Smurf hair and he's just like 20 minutes
in I'm like
he's been up there and I I liked it I
thought it got over I liked he was up
there like we made up he was up there 15
minutes and then he started in this
thing where we need to start telling
people who are helping us now and who we
appreciate that we appreciate them now
so he just started reading this list of
people that it's serious yeah yeah was I
on there they make the list like I know
I think was like re I can't remember but
no I just named euro sentiment is good
like and maybe not he was he was already
been up there awhile when he oh yeah I
mean everyone's like can we [ __ ] go
are you earthquake are you running the
[ __ ] life right now yeah I mean I
literally did two minutes and I like him
though and I thought I did a good job
to be clear Nick yeah he's such an
interesting person we talked when we we
yeah I went up to my goal listen I I
know we I don't know what happened what
day we talked but it might have been at
that thing but we were just like do
scissoring with we bump [ __ ] what
just to [ __ ] you and thank you old Moses
bummer
speaking of Yusef and fake butts dana
Dearman guy a fake but recently i love
her yeah yeah and fake boobs this do by
the way
porn stars big butt porn stars are so
much like comics she literally has her
own podcast it's called webcaming yeah
they do that exact same business model t
like an industry podcast about know if
she's literally fingerblast herself
that's her podcast oh I see right
because there's no morning important so
now these girls have to do this [ __ ]
one-on-one [ __ ] yeah I think they make a
lot probably do well the girl that this
girl is to hang out with she was like
one of the top girls for my free cams
and she was pulling in like forty
thousand a month crazy and the money now
correct me if I'm wrong but the money is
you get to tell or ask the girl yeah
like shove that bat in your [ __ ]
they'll be like okay bye tokens
and that's just like throwing money
onstage pretty much yeah
that's interesting mm-hmm all right I
would think the couples would do better
today or is it yeah couples do pretty
good actually pretty good you know
especially because this is what you've
heard on the street yeah that's what I
heard from the street Matt the couples
are always interesting because you know
it's like it's like swingers you know
they're not always the best-looking or
it's like how the [ __ ] is this guy this
girl I want the guy to be no one to be
too vocal or not just Nazis face exactly
porn is like comedy everybody thinks
they could do it have you noticed that
yeah it's everybody thinks they're great
at and then you actually watch yourself
you're like okay I don't need to do that
again guys this has been a great show
Ryan read Ben's gonna come by all the
time every time as long as he wants he's
gonna do the final hour so we're gonna
get our ARF we're gonna get our sports
and early then we'll have sports man
come in crunch numbers and then we'll
talk about just how no fake butts and
Tesla's Aaron Ida great show yesterday
[ __ ] you all right you guys are great
we'll see you next week see you guys at
the UFC fights out the [ __ ] guys dojo
side the standard or inside the Sycamore
bye everybody